first of the defense you see for ending
the show that we do in the boat but for
still relatively little if it happened
if there's more sort of screen time what
would do you do so wait in between the
Lighting's you'd imagine you'd or you
know who has what would you add in sorts
of things well as preparations the
second series I wrote myself for that
was a short story about what Loras and
really did between the seasons
which involve negotiating military
strategy with mace Tyrell and methi
mathri inhale that one and the marriage
and and I guess if I think actually as
characters then going to meet Alice's
father and negotiating marriage of
Marjorie once I started thinking about
actually that's quite an interesting
story so if they were like that's been
off Regnier Norrish oh yeah I think that
chapter of his life would be quite
interesting I also would like would be
interested to see him as a young girl I
was a child growing up and that core
when when Robert was a real war hero
like lifting up to his older brothers
and why he was so different from them I
know there's a kitchen table but there's
every character in that the reason why
it's such good dramas every character
you could write a whole spin-off show
just about each character because
they're fully fleshed out
you